We spend a lot of time looking at
the basic theory of prototyping.
You know enough by now to know that
these things are only useful if you
actually build them.
So let's get started on that.
The fundamental idea behind prototypes
is that your making the fastest
version of a thing that can get
you the information you need
from the people you need it from.
To that end, it's useful to think about
what the fastest possible prototyping
method would be,
since that's what you'll want for
your first two prototypes.
We'll be showing you two options,
either of which work for your own app or
our example app.
Behind this curtain is your best friend,
the tool that will allow you to
prototype and
pivot faster than any other tool.
Get ready.
Yeah, look at that.
Sketching your prototypes
simply on paper is the single
best way to work on prototypes when
you're starting a project from scratch,
and it allows you to
change course very easily.
You can redo parts of your designs
during user testing in order to
clarify things that are being
called out as confusing.
These paper prototypes are going
to be super low fidelity but
they will give you enough of an idea of
your app that their feedback will tell
you if you're going in
the right direction.
There's one other method of
fast prototyping that's behind
this other curtain.
Prepare to be amazed.
[SOUND] Yeah.
That's a printer.
When you've gone through the work
of making mocks for an app,
you can build a simple paper prototype
by printing out these mocks.
If you have mocks from
the product design course,
this rap could be for you.
Both methods will work for us here, and
they will both lead to
great user feedback.